[音楽]
というわけでどこに行くでしょうはいいい
今日初めてに入っていただくのは9蔵原と音です
q 蔵原トンネルはい
1968年に作りますわー
me
だから20年後に新しいトンネルで帰還するなるほどで使われることがなくなったと
少女の霊が出るという噂があり
また変し延べ兵種弊社いるそうです
心霊スポットそのなんていうかこう朝ランキングで言うと
max 5ポイントの410時でした結構高江あっあの障害をくれました
敵メンバーの傭兵前提です
んですよね同じ富山県出身なんですよこっそり畑下の新メンバーになりました
トマトくんです
なんで富山に来たのにあった静岡の服着ていたいなぁなんで3人で来たかっていうと
心霊スポットって奇数で行くとすれてくれませんですよ連れてくる前提付きましたけど
今日はお持ち帰りしましょう宮倉花トンネル
このメンバーで行ってみようと思います
じゃああああ
バッハ僕もにもうどっかにも使ってもはいつか今言って
安心しますよ
やばいです
西川されましたーーー
少しん
おっ
いません
帰ってきますうん
ん
えっ俺 a 1名しかあたってねバーダーわー
あっホテルレスキューたんだ
よかったもう設け宣教アウトーケース入りますそれではまた飾っていけています
ウイルスでギブ
いう選挙に帰って来ませんあれどういうルールなんですかカーズん
me
ブービー名誉プレオアメリカ nuby ルシアーダソニーのロシアのプーラーヌー
あーなるほどね9人特急そっぱファンたんですよ
だろこんなじゃないですかそんな
源さんから始まるん
voodoo アーム maybe あめりかー
ben jelen 者は r アーメーン4号でアメリカっちで次あれッスハ13
ゲスある答える
あおえええ
ああそうだろう異聞ねえんだけどここ本当じゃないけどあなたてるがビュー s ねー
usa
カーム maybe アメリカあっブーブー青い c ううううかウォン baby
ちゅうーだいたいぬーんぬー
ran やばい月というエッセイいう劣勢
カームモンベベイビーに on
京都って意外とつまんねー10 wandered 寿司かねぇパスから脱げて歌子は
カヌー sa バーガームーンベイビー日本
ban
またであっ例えばサーモンメイミーシンガポル
マーライ4がる国 oo
母もんベイビーポルトガル
a
ずっと良い国いい母も姉 a
日本
周りに流されすぎよ母もんメイでぃアルゼンチンメッシがいる国だねぇ
母もんビビリ便バナナがせぬほどあろう
母もんえーい banar
street rag どれ ender ender ender ender あー
もう maybe a ラフランス
ピザが多いイタリアでぜやばい街灯が本当にないです
ねいう制限も楽しかった意外だまではだわるって言われる
やっぱはやるだけはありましょうデイさんの話によると
やっぱ
この近所に住んでるが救ってはいん
日本人たちいわくやっぱりすごい強いって言ってますよね
ちなみに田舎地下席いくとガードレールが安くて
はいその後れるからもうすごい恐怖を感じると ar レールから地獄を応援し柄の1
人
ブーブーあると思うんですけど
このアイディアのちょっとさっきをこのマーカーれたもうちょいつなぐ here
ロードこれが seen here そろそろ君
ですかええいい数える誰々図りだりねこれじゃあって言わリーダーや梅丸だあれですっ
て
はいと湯気で到着しましたトンネル入口です左側
おります
[音楽]
本当ここここ何
これまた目
2ボムティーズ金入って今 g 1ですねー
ね作家が刺さってるんですか
ないよ
ちょっと奥までてらっしゃるよん
トヨエツをトンネル前まで来たんですけどご覧ください
[音楽]
通行止めでございますでこのマーク実はクルマだけじゃなくて歩行者も一切
通行が掲示されるっていうマークなんであのトンネルには一応こっち側からは入れませ
ん
トンネルってことはこっちがじゃなくて向こうがもあるということなのであっ違うから
を見てみたいな
なりっ子苦節落ちたを伝うよ
に負かさといった z いったよ抹茶作業を言ってるんでまず者
いや聞きましたねー
って声が聞こえたん
矢崎この1点じゃまずポスターされてないですがそこの確かに確かに
音瀬町伝えてくださっていった絶対打ったり会社で1回も聴けました
[音楽]
いよいよ明日
パネルことビダムうーわー
ジャンカチで止めんでしょうねってが珍しくないですか心霊スポットって2入れるです
よ飛んでるとかマジでやばいんじゃないからさっき級って書いてあると思う
まあ中だから取れないのかな普通は
悔しいところでありますね
そうなね
ただ安全的マジじゃないですかね危ないんだと思いますんだよ
ちょっとそちらにたじゃないけどそうですわー
あぶはっはあああああ
goo
えーったんじゃないんだなぁか入りたくないですわー
一ああああ
マッハだちゃん
プー帰ろうぜ説明しますかじゃいっ
どうすか
under 1位はなぜバスれたも行くでしょ風香 g 4 yasu これが
ランクダウンスキッポンですね実際の交通規制にスタイルだけど
続押してください
わー
anus ちゃぷちゃうぅううドゥエ恋